you see the Clippers writing down in the  zone Guzman we just came in as a good  way to start your Christmas game goes by  hits a three-pointer Lakers back up by  two  [Music]  Kuzma off the dribble turns fires and  tacks this second field goal we see on  the offensive end Koopa does a great job  getting to his spot using his body for a  little breathing room Aiza Leonard it's  just overwhelming him in the paint  Leonard averaging 25 and a half per game  as ku spot red hot off the bench  a 14-point opening period for Leonard  kuzmic tribes backs down one with the  Celtics hoping to get one with the  Lakers who Smith is hot fires away  [Applause]  3331 Lakers after one